no one likes paying higher prices which
is why for most of 2022 inflation has
been one of the biggest issues on
Americans Minds this historic bout of
inflation is primarily the result of how
the covid-19 pandemic upset the global
economy exacerbated by the war in
Ukraine the FED has been raising
interest rates in an effort to pump the
brakes on Rising prices and if it works
we should finally see the economic
Legacy of covid Fade Into the past
however there's something else driving
price hikes that's far beyond the reach
of the central bank to solve climate
change I'm sure you've heard plenty
about how a warming Planet will hurt
polar bears and coral reefs and beach
houses on the Florida coast but the
economic impacts of climate change will
trickle down to everyone even if you
don't live in a flood zone your
pocketbook will get soaked
foreign
[Music]
there are three main categories of costs
that climate change will affect and the
first is energy here in Texas air
conditioning is ubiquitous and it's
pretty much a given that you're running
it non-stop from May to September but as
global temperatures rise many other
regions and cities that don't normally
rely so heavily on AC we'll start using
more and more electricity to cool their
homes this will be offset somewhat by
less demand for heating fuels like oil
and natural gas in the winter time but
the net effect will be an increase in
most Americans energy bills in fact it's
already happening the average monthly
electric bill in the U.S increased by
around 10 percent in the last 10 years
over the same time period average
monthly consumption fell by 2.3 percent
probably due to the growing popularity
of energy saving appliances and lighting
so if it wasn't for Green Tech the
increase would have been even greater
unfortunately many economists expect
Energy prices to rise even higher than
Market forces would predict for two
reasons one increasing energy production
doesn't mean just turning up a dial much
of our energy infrastructure was built
decades ago with specific limits on
capacity to meet increasing demand
providers will have to renovate existing
structures build new plants and lay new
cables and pipelines all of this costs
money which they will pass on to the
consumers in the form of higher prices
the second reason is that most existing
power plants use water for cooling
higher temperatures means more
evaporation which means less water and
warmer water and pumping water in from
other regions requires you guessed it
energy increasing demand even further so
these plants will likely run at a lower
efficiency than they did in the past
especially in the very places where
demand for electricity will be highest
the upshot is that you can expect to pay
more to power your home in the future
technology built around sustainable
energy like like solar panels won't get
you completely off the grid anytime soon
but it will start making economic sense
to more and more households especially
if a federal subsidy can help with those
installation costs the next sector of
the economy that will see significant
price hikes thanks to climate change is
food most of that is due to extreme
weather even before the war in Ukraine
upset that country's grain exports the
price of wheat had surged to its highest
level in eight years mainly the result
of high temperatures in the U.S and
Canada in fact as of the summer of 2022
more than 95 percent of the western U.S
is in some level of drought in 2021
drought and high temperatures caused 93
percent of wheat produced in Washington
state to be in poor or very poor
condition to make matters worse price
hikes caused by drought can often be
self-exacerbating for example when water
is scarce in California it drives up the
price of thirsty crops like almonds and
pistachios perversely this makes those
crops more lucrative motivating Farmers
to grow more of them and further
depleting the water supply economists
call this unfortunate phenomenon the
tragedy of the comments but it's not
just droughts in 2021 less than a year
after coffee prices had recovered from a
drought in Brazil they rose again this
time because of extreme Frost here in
Texas in that same year a deep freeze
caused at least 600 million dollars in
agricultural losses and Other Extreme
weather events like floods and
hurricanes can increase the cost of
transporting food from the farm to your
table
of course as long as there's been
agriculture humans have been dealing
with inclement weather if one food
source had a bad year consumers could
supplement with another what makes this
period so unprecedented is that so many
crops are in crisis simultaneously that
makes it much harder for the average
person to escape the economic effects
the third sector of the economy that
climate change will upend is Insurance
particularly in Property and Casualty
Insurance which protects homes cars and
personal belongings this sector took in
around 1.6 trillion dollars in premium
payments in 2020 alone insurance is
supposed to function as a safety net if
Calamity befalls one person the
collected payments of everyone else can
save them from Financial ruin but as
floods hurricanes and wildfires become
more common it's changing the math
insured losses from natural disasters in
2021 reached 130 billion dollars almost
twice the yearly average insurers are
responding by raising their premiums
with the average U.S homeowner insurance
payment increasing by 11.4 percent since
2017. but if you live near a Coast or in
a flood plain you might see a much
steeper premium hike since 1968 the
federal government has been subsidizing
flood insurance through the national
flood insurance program which allows
homeowners in flood-prone areas to buy
insurance at far lower rates than what a
traditional insurance company would
charge in 2019 FEMA announced that they
would reprice these policies to more
accurately reflect the risks this is
meant to keep the program solvent and
discourage new building in areas
threatened by climate change but it's
also a question of fairness for decades
middle and low income families who live
inland have been paying more for their
insurance so that wealthy people can pay
less for their mansions on the coast how
much less according to the New York
Times some Florida homeowners may
eventually pay up to 10 times more for
their flood insurance once the price
change takes effect yowza
whether it's energy food or Insurance
how much more you'll pay in the future
depends a lot on where you live but
virtually no one will get away scot-free
the global economy is remarkably
versatile and resilient but if the
pandemic taught us anything it's that
when a crisis hits many different
sectors and economy simultaneously
that's when things can get really bad
and that's exactly what climate change
is poised to do but it's not entirely
Bleak if governments and industries
around the world can respond with
policies that cut carbon emissions and
develop new more efficient Technologies
we can still avoid the worst case
scenario for decades some have argued
that fighting climate change is too
expensive but that's like deciding not
to spend the money to fix a leak in your
roof eventually when the roof caves in
the damage will cost far more than the
fix I guess the difference is that if
your house is destroyed you can still
move to another one that's not quite the
case with planet Earth
and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
[Music]
to find out how you can offset the costs
of climate change in your own house
check out our video can you really save
money by going green